en este vídeo vamos a discutir la
desigualdad de ingresos que es algo que
a menudo se debate al pensar en comparar
países analizar si se trata de un
problema o no y cómo abordarlo y para
comprender qué es la desigualdad de
ingresos imaginemos dos países
diferentes
primero imaginemos el país y hay dos
personas en el país y aquí tienes una
persona que gana mil pesos al año ese es
su ingreso y luego está la persona 2 en
el país que gana 99 mil pesos al año así
que cuál será el ingreso promedio en el
país a si estas son las únicas dos
personas o podrías pensarlo como el
ingreso nacional per cápita bueno para
calcular el ingreso promedio sólo
tendrías que promediar 1000 y 99 mil
entonces tienes un ingreso total de mil
más 99 mil que es igual a 100 mil
dividido entre dos personas y tendrás un
ingreso promedio de 50 mil pesos al año
ahora permítanme construir otro país que
tenga el mismo ingreso promedio pero la
distribución es muy diferente entonces
en el país ve digamos que el primer
ciudadano del país ve gana 50 mil pesos
al año y digamos que hay una segunda
persona en el país ve y también gana 50
mil pesos al año
bueno cuál es el ingreso promedio ahora
esto es aún más fácil de calcular 50 más
50 dividido entre 2 su ingreso promedio
es de 50 mil pesos al año entonces lo
que ves aquí son dos países que si solo
observas el ingreso promedio parecen ser
igualmente ricos tienen ingresos
promedios similares así que podrías
decir que tal vez son igualmente
prósperos pero cuando lo revisas más
profundo ves que son muy diferentes el
país
es mucho más desigual de ingresos que el
país ve entonces la pregunta es cómo se
mide la desigualdad está más allá de
revisar cosas como el ingreso promedio o
el pib promedio o el pib per cápita y
eso es algo que trato de abordar el
estadista italiano corrado gini y se le
ocurrió algo que fue llamado el
coeficiente de gini para medir la disip
de ingresos en una nación y la forma en
que lo abordó es en realidad bastante
intuitiva lo que hizo fue poner dos ejes
este eje será el porcentaje acumulado de
la población así que empiezas en 0% y
luego llegas hasta 100 por ciento de la
población entonces este es el porcentaje
acumulado de la población en un país y
luego en este eje está el porcentaje
acumulado de ingresos en un país de modo
que sería cero aquí abajo y luego 100
acá arriba así que este es el porcentaje
acumulado de ingresos en un país y luego
dijo bueno cómo sería una sociedad con
perfecta igualdad bueno en una sociedad
perfectamente igualitaria a medida que
agregas un porcentaje a su porcentaje
acumulado de población debes agregar
exactamente el mismo porcentaje a su
porcentaje acumulado de ingresos así que
a medida que su vez realmente deberías
tener una pendiente que sube así por lo
tanto una manera de pensar en esto es
que cuando estás en el 0% de la
población
debes tener el 0 por ciento de los
ingresos
si tienes un total de 10 por ciento de
la población deberías tener el 10% del
ingreso nacional si tuvieras el 50 por
ciento de la población lo que parece que
está por aquí y los ingresos se
distribuyeron perfectamente igual
entonces deberías estar en el 50 por
ciento del ingreso nacional pero ninguna
nación está realmente así y entonces
tenemos que comparar eso con la realidad
digamos que miras a un país y lo que
haces es que cuando observas el
porcentaje acumulado de la población
comienzas por la izquierda con los
ingresos más bajos y a medida que sumas
los porcentajes de la población llegas a
las personas de ingresos más y más altos
así que digamos que estamos viendo un
país que para las personas más pobres
a medida que agregas porcentajes a la
población acumulada no agregas el mismo
porcentaje a los ingresos acumulados y
entonces podrías tener una curva que se
parece a esto
y luego a medida que agregas porcentajes
en la población más rica por cada 1% que
agrega si agregas más del 1% del ingreso
nacional de modo que esta curva justo
aquí que podrías ver como una
descripción de la realidad de una
determinada nación se conoce como curva
de lawrence y lo que jim y dijo es que
la diferencia entre la curva de lawrence
y esta línea recta sería una medida de
la desigualdad de ingresos y así el miro
esta área justo aquí y dijo qué
porcentaje representa esta área entre
esta recta y la curva de lawrence del
área total debajo de la recta y a este
porcentaje se le denomina coeficiente de
gini y por lo general se cita como un
valor entre 0 y 1 o en ocasiones se ve
en una escala de 0 a 100 entonces que
representaría un coeficiente de gini
igual a 0 bueno si tienes un coeficiente
de gini igual a cero eso significa que
esta área justo aquí entre la curva de
lawrence y esta recta es igual a cero
eso significa que estamos tratando con
una distribución de ingreso
perfectamente igual
entonces en el extremo 0 tenemos
igualdad perfecta perfecta igualdad de
ingresos y qué significa 1 100 eso
significa que el área entre la línea y
la curva de lawrence es el 100% del área
debajo de esta línea así que se vería
como algo así un país cuya curva de
lawrence se ve así donde agregamos todas
estas personas más y más y más población
pero no estoy agregando ingresos y de
repente llegas a la última persona y esa
persona tiene todos los ingresos
entonces esta persona tiene todos los
ingresos bueno en ese caso el
coeficiente de gini sería el porcentaje
de esta área que sería del 100% aunque
podríamos ver como 1 o 100 y es
interesante observar los coeficientes de
gini para varios países y compararlos y
eso es exactamente lo que tenemos en
este mapa podemos ver que los países que
están sombreados en rojo son países que
tienen altos coeficientes de jim y por
lo tanto tienen más desigualdad de
ingresos
y los que están sombreados en verde son
aquellos que tienen índices de gini o
coeficiente de gini relativamente bajos
por lo que sería indicativo de una
desigualdad de ingresos razonablemente
baja ahora es importante señalar que
podrías pensar que el rojo siempre es
malo y el verde siempre es bueno pero
esto solo nos indica la desigualdad no
nos indica en promedio que tan prospera
es la gente que ingresos promedio tiene
ese país de modo que esto es una
indicación de que en lugares como
américa latina y áfrica subshariana
definitivamente tienen una desigualdad
muy alta y lugares como canadá y europa
parece que tienen una desigualdad muy
baja pero eso no indica que seguramente
esta gente está mejor en canadá que
digamos en eeuu por ejemplo podríamos
ver un ingreso promedio más alto en los
eeuu que en canadá y uno puede tener un
debate muy animado sobre en cual país
preferiría estar prefieres estar en un
país que tiene mayor desigualdad y un
ingreso promedio más alto o en uno que
tenga ingresos más bajos
una desigualdad más baja